اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
بعد الوثائق السريه واشنطن تطمئن الحلفاء
القليقين
يحذر من خطوره تسريبها على الامن القومي
ونتيجه الوثائق المسربه كيف تستبعد اجراء
اي تعديلات على خططها لشن هجوم مضاد مرتقب
ضد روسيا
وتزامنا مع اقتحام جنين القوات
الاسرائيليه تشدد الاجراءات في القدس
وعشرات المستوطنين يقتحمون الاقصى
[موسيقى]
بريطانيا تستعد لاضراب خطير للاطباء
احتجاجا على الاجور وتحذيرات من شلل في
قطاع الرعايه الصحيه
اهلا بكم نبدا من ازمه الوثائق السريه
الامريكيه المسربه والتي تعدت حدود
الولايات المتحده دول وحكومات وردت
اسمائها في الوثائق ادت خشيتها من تبعات
تسريب الملفات السريه فيما قلل الدول
الاخرى من تاثيرها واشنطن من جانبها
تحاوركم ان حلفائها القليقين حيث افادت
صحيفه بوليتيكو بتوجه كبار المسؤولين
والممثلي اجهزه الاستخبارات ووزاره
الخارجيه وحتى البنتاجون الى زملائهم
لتبريد المخاوف بشان نشر معلومات
استخباراتيه ولا يزال مصدر التسريب قيد
التحقيق في الولايات المتحده التي تحاول
الان بتحديد حجم التسريب من دون ابداء مدى
خطورته حيث حذر البنتاغون من ان تسريب
الوثائق السريه يشكل خطرا جسيما للغايه
على الامن القومي الامريكي
وزاره الدفاع ستحول القضيه الى وزاره
العدل للتحقيق الجنائي لكن لا اعتقد انهم
وصلوا الى اي نتيجه حول كيفيه التسريب
الوثائق ولا حجم الضرر على الامن القومي
وفي وثيقه مسربه جديده كشفت صحيفه واشنطن
احد الوثائق ان الاستخبارات الامريكيه
تشكك في ان الهجوم المضاده الاوكرانيه
المرتقب هذا الربيع سيتمكن من تحقيق
اهدافه وبحسب الوثيقه المسربه فان
التقييمات الاستخباراتيه الامريكيه تحذر
من النواقص فيما يخص حشد القوات وامدادها
مرجحه ان العمليه الهجوميه الاوكرانيه
ستؤدي الى مكاسب محدوده على الارض واشارت
واشنطن بوست ايضا الى ان التقييمات التي
جاءت في الوثائق المسربه تختلف عما جاء في
التصريحات العلنيه للاداره الامريكيه بشان
قدرات الجيش الاوكراني عموما بعد
التسريبات المتعلقه او المتعلقه في حرب
اوكرانيا افادت شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه
بان كييف مضطره لتعديل بعض خططها العسكريه
قبل هجومها المضاد والمرتقب هذا الربيع
والذي طال انتظاره بسبب الوثائق السريه
لكن كيف نفت الامر واكدت ان خطه الهجوم
المضاد لم تتاثر بتسريب الوثائق وفي تبعات
الوثائق المسربه ايضا رجعها اعلان الرئاسه
الكوريه الجنوبيه ان احتمال التنصت على
الاجتماعات والمكالمات داخل مجمع المكتب
الرئاسي في يوم صن من اي طرف هو احتمال
ضئيل وقال مسؤولون في كوريا الجنوبيه ان
كل المكاتب داخل المجمع الرئاسي في يونغ
سون مزود بانظمه امنيه صارمه للغايه
لمكافحه التنصت كما نفى المكتب الرئاسي
ايضا احتمال اي تسريب من محتويات اجتماعات
مجلس الامن القومي او الوطني التي تجري في
القبو المحصن في الطابق الثالث تحت الارض
وذلك من خلال اعتراضها والتجسس عليها هذا
وكانت كوريا الجنوبيه مشاهدينا اوضحت ان
الوثائق السريه الامريكيه المسربه غير
حقيقيه وحتى محرفه ومن بين التسريبات
المتداوله على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وثيقه تتضمن تفاصيل مناقشه داخليه
المسؤوليين كوريين جنوبيين حول الضغط
الامريكي على سول للمساعده في تزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه وبحسب الوثيقه فان
كوريا الجنوبيه وافقت على بيع قذائف
مدفعيه لمساعده الولايات المتحده في اعاده
تكوين مخزوناتها وفي هذا الشان قالت كوريا
الجنوبيه ان قوانينها تمنع تزويد الدول
المنخرطه في صراعات بالاسلحه وهو ما يعني
عدم قدرتها على ارسال الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا حول ذلك ينضم الينا من واشنطن
المحلل السياسي ايهاب عباس اهلا بك معنا
سيد ايهاب اذا تسريبات لوثائق سببت بعض
القلق عند الحلفاء او الدول التي وردت في
هذه الوثائق ربما كوريا الجنوبيه احد
الامثله هل الخطر القومي الذي يحذر منه
البنتاغون يطال الامن القومي للدول الاخرى
نعم اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بكل المشاهدين
اينما كانوا بالفعل هذه حقيقه طبعا هناك
مخاوف كبيره لدى حلفاء واشنطن وشركائها
خاصه في الملفات الكبيره التي من الممكن
ان تشكل
قلقا خلال الفتره القادمه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والدول التي تشارك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الكثير من المعلومات والبيانات
الخاصه بها سواء على المستوى الداخلي او
على المستوى علاقاتها الخارجيه طبعا كوريا
الجنوبيه من احدى هذه الدول وتدرس هذه
الوثائق بعنايه شديده جدا وصدر منها تصريح
قبل ساعات من انها تعتقد ان هذه الوثائق
مزيفه وليست حقيقيه وهذا طبعا بعكس وخلاف
كل ما يصرح به المسؤولون الامريكيون من
انه يبدو ان هذه الوثائق حقيقيه وانها تم
تسريبها من داخل الولايات المتحده بشكل او
باخر
واستدلوا على ذلك
ببعض الصور التي ظهرت على حسابات تيليجرام
والتي اوضحت فيها وامشها انه ربما تكون
بالفعل قد سربت من داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذا يعني ان هناك سيكون ربما
اشخاص امريكيون متورطون في تسريب هذه
المعلومات وربما في نهايه المطاف تكشف
وزاره العاده الامريكيه ان هناك خرقه او
اختراقا لاجهزه الاستخبارات الامريكيه
بشكل
سيشكل طبعا مفاجاه كبيره نعم سيد ايهاب
هناك قلق من هذه التسريبات وهناك يعني
ربما معلومات متضاربه هناك تصريحات ايضا
متضاربه من البيت الابيض يطمئن البنتاجون
يحذر ولكن السؤال الاهم ربما هو من
المستفيد من هذه التسريبات
يعني على المستوى الخارجي المستفيد ستكون
طبعا هي الدول المنافسه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه او الدول الاعداء التي تصنفها
واشنطن على انها عدوه عدوه لها على
المستوى الداخلي اذا ما تكشفت ان هناك
اشخاص داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ساهموا في هذا التسريب هنا سنقف امام هويه
هؤلاء الاشخاص اما اذا كانوا امريكيين او
كانوا من جنسيات اخرى داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وعندها ستكون ايضا هناك
مشكلات كبيره ومفاجاه لانه من الممكن ان
يكون هؤلاء الاشخاص ينتمون مثلا في الاصل
الى روسيا الى الصين الى اي دول اخرى وهذا
سيعني ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
اجراءاتها الامنيه المتعلقه بالتحقق من
هويه هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين تمنحهم مثلا
جنسيتها او تعطي لهم حق المكوث او اللجوء
او الاقامه داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والعمل استطاعوا ان يخترقوا
الاجهزه الامنيه والاستخباراتيه الخاصه
بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه للحصول على
هذه
معلومات السريه المهمه جدا وهنا ستكون
مراجعه شامله لكل الاجراءات والقوانين
المتعلقه
الى اي مدى هو فعلا خطير على الامن القومي
الى اي مدى هو يؤثر على الوضع الداخلي في
امريكا
خطر بشكل كبير جدا لانه سيعني ان هناك
اختراق لاجهزه الاستخبارات الامريكيه
والمؤسسات الفيدراليه الامريكيه ما يعني
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من الممكن
ان تتسرب من خلالها معلومات بكميات اكبر
مما نشاهده اليوم وهذا سيكون في مصلحه
المنافسين بشكل كبير جدا خاصه الصين وتاتي
من بعدها روسيا انا اعتقد ان الصين هي
الخطر الاكبر على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وليس روسيا الصين ستكون لديها
قاعده بيانات كبيره جدا ونعلم ان واشنطن
اصلا تتهم الصين بانها تقوم بسرقه بيانات
المواطنين الامريكيين والحكومه الامريكيه
والفدراليه فلذلك اعتقد سيكون هذا الملف
ربما ملف القرن او على الاقل تقديم ملف
العقد الذي نحن بصدده اليوم لانه سيشكل
مخاوف امنيه كبيره جدا لدى واشنطن في وقت
هي اصلا تستعد لمجابهه الصين مثلا في ملف
تايوان طبعا في الملفات الاخرى في الملفات
التجاره والاتصال وخصوصا اننا نشهد
التوترات بين البلدين تتصاعد في الاونه
الاخيره شكرا لك من واشنطن المحلل السياسي
ايهاب عباس
الى بخموت تتبع روسيا سياسه الارض
المحروقه هكذا يبدو الوضع مع تعرض المدينه
شرق اوكرانيا لقصف روسي عنيف استهدف خطوط
الجبهه الشرقيه ودمر اجزاء كبيره من
المدينه وباتت معركه بخموت الاكثر دمويه
في الحرب المستمره منذ اكثر من عام تكبد
فيها الجانبان خسائر كبيره ومع التصعيد
الاخير في المدينه تشير تقارير عسكريه الى
ان القوات الروسيه تسيطر الان على 75% من
المدينه لكن من السابق لاوانه الحديث عن
سقوط باخموت فيما يقر الجانب الاوكراني
بصعوبه الوضع لكن لا تزال القوات تقاوم
متمسكه بالسيطره على المدينه القوات
الروسيه حولت افديفكا في باخموت الى دمار
كامل مع القصف الجوي والمدفعي الاخير
بينما لم يبقى الكثير من المباني على حاله
اول بلده كبيره الى الغرب من بخموت وتعزز
موسكو جبهه القتال بارسال المزيد من
القوات الخاصه الى بخ موت بعد انهاك قوات
فاجنر الخاصه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في المقابل افاد مسؤول في مجموعه فستق
العسكريه الروسيه
بان القوات الروسيه صدت محاوله القوات
الاوكرانيه لهجوم المعاكسين باتجاه جنوب
دنيتك شرق اوكرانيا وفق المسؤول الروسيلي
لوكاله تاس تم القضاء ايضا على ما يصل الى
عشره مقاتلين مع تدمير مدفعيه ذاتيه
الحركه روسيه من طرازنت لمدفع هاون تابع
للجيش الاوكراني ينضم الينا من دنيتك
مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر اهلا بك معنا
رائد اذن تطورات ومعارك مستمره في باخ موت
انقل لنا الصوره والمعلومات المتوفره لديك
صباح الخير فاطمه
باخمت هو المحور الاهم كالعاده في الشرق
الاوكراني الذي تستعر فيه المعارك في مدن
عديده لكن مدينه باخموت هي الاكثر سخونه
في المعارك حيث ما زالت قوات فاجنر تطوق
المدينه من الثلاث نواحي الجنوبيه
والشرقيه والشماليه هناك معارك في المنطقه
الشماليه حول بلده
اريخكا تحاول قوات الروسيه اكمال الطوق من
هذه الناحيه وايصال نقاط التماس مع بلده
بقدانه في المنطقه الغربيه التي ما زالت
القوات الاوكرانيه تسيطر عليها لو استطاع
الجيش الروسي او قوات فاجنر من السيطره
والوصل بين هاتين النقطتين فهذا يعني بان
الطوق يكون قد اكتمل على المدينه الا
مناطق في الناحيه الجنوبيه الغربيه حيث
مدينه قسطنطينه كانعلم فاطمه بان المنطقه
الغربيه هي التي يسيطر عليها الجيش
الاوكراني من مدينه باخموت وصولا الى قلب
حيث مناطق سكك الحديد هناك معارك ضاره
اشرس المعارك تدور في منطقه سكك الحديد
تحاول قوات فاجنر السيطره على هذه المنطقه
لكن هناك مقاومه عنيفه من قبل الجيش
الاوكراني هناك ايضا نقاط مختلفه في
المحور الجنوبي والشمالي للقوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت هناك تحصينات اوكرانيه
وتصلهم الامدادات عبر طريقين كان يعني
المعروف ان هناك طريق واحد وهو طريق
تشاسوفيا لكن امس قامت القوات الروسيه
بمحاوله قطع الطريق من مدينه قسطنطينه على
مدينه عفوا الى مدينه باقمت وهذا دليل على
ان ايضا امدادات عسكريه تصل من منطقه
قسطنطينه الى المقاتلين في مدينه باقمر
سلاح الجو ما زال يحلق فوق مدينه باخموت
ويقصف قواعد للقوات الاوكرانيه حسب
التصريحات التي تصلنا من ارض المعركه
ان هناك معارك في جميع المحاور الجنوبيه
والشرقيه حول مواقع تمركز الجيش الاوكراني
كما اسلفت يوم امس زار دينيس بوشيلين زعيم
الانفصالين هنا في مدينه باقمت مع مسؤولين
مع مسؤولين حكومينا من موسكو وقال بان
القوات الروسيه او الجيش الروسي بشكل عام
سيطر على ما نسبته 75% من المدينه وان
السيطره على كامل المدينه بات وشيكا ليس
محور باخمه وحده لكن هناك محاور عديده اذا
سمح الوقت وبعجال فاطمه
هي الاكثر سخونه حتى انها اكثر سخونه من
باقي خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه هناك هجمات
عديده ومحاولات اقتحامات
متكرره منذ الصباح الباكر وحتى يوم امس
كانت هناك محاولات ايضا
يعني سلاح الجو الرو القصف مواقع في للجيش
الاوكراني على اطراف المدينه ومحاوله
اختراق المدينه لاول مره حتى الان لم تفلح
هذه المحاولات لكن العمليات العسكريه التي
شهدتها مدينه افديفيكا كانت غير مسبوقه من
قبل الجيش الروسي تبقى مدينه مارينكا وهي
التي يسيطر الجيش الروسي على ثلثي المدينه
منها بالامس سيطره على بلده فودينيو وهي
اول تقدم له في هذا المحور من الناحيه
الغربيه منذ فتره طويله معارك ضاريه في
المناطق الجنوبيه تستعر المعارك المساله
الاهم وبعجولا ايضا فاطمه ان يوم امس شهد
اعلانات من قبل الحكومه الروسيه ومن قبل
السلطات هنا بالعوده الى المنازل من
المكاتب الحكوميه تحسبا من ضربه قويه ربما
تواجهها اوكرانيا الى المدنيين مدينه
دمياط على كل هذه التفاصيل من دنيتك
مستمرون معكم ونتابع في كتابي هل الازرق
السنوي اليابان تعتبر الصين اكبر تحد
استراتيجي للنظام الدولي
احييكم من جديد اقتحمت قواته اسرائيليه
مخيم جنين في الضفه الغربيه فجر اليوم حيث
اندلعت مواجهات مع شبان فلسطينيين وذكر
مراسل العربيه ان القوات الاسرائيليه
اعتقلت نجل ماهر تركمان المتهم بتنفيذ
عمليه في منطقه الاغوار في سبتمبر الماضي
وبعد محاصره منزله اضافه الى اعتقال اربعه
فلسطينيين اخرين في جنين وبموازاه ذلك
اندلعت اشتباكات بين شبان فلسطينيين
والقوات الاسرائيليه في نابلس
تحت
التصعيد في الضفه الغربيه مشاهدينا شددت
القوات الاسرائيليه اجراءاتها في القدس
القديمه ومنعت شبان من دخول المسجد الاقصى
وتاديه صلاه الفجر فيه فيما يتواصل اقتحام
المستوطنين باحات المسجد ونفذ المستوطنون
اقتحاماتهم على شكل مجموعات للمسجد الاقصى
والصحمايه مشدده من الشرطه الاسرائيليه
التي ابعدت المصلين الفلسطينيين عن مسار
اقتحامات المستوطنين هذا وقد نشرت الشرطه
عناصرها ووحداتها الخاصه في ساحات الاقصى
وعند ابوابه مع استمرار اقتحامات
المستوطنين
معنا من القدس مدير مكتب العربيه زياد
حلبي اهلا بك معنا زياد
اقتحامات للقوات الاسرائيليه لجنين وهناك
تجديد امني في القدس القديمه وكذلك اقتحام
عشرات المستوطنين للمسجد الاقصى انقل لنا
الصوره لديك
هذا صحيح يعني اكثر من 700 مستوطن ومتطرف
يهودي اقتحموا الساحات المسجد الاقصى
عمليا تحت حراسه من الشرطه الاسرائيليه
منذ ساعات الصباح بعد ربع ساعه من الان
ستنتهي الاقتحامات سيغلق باب المغاربه
الذي يقتحمون منه ويخرجون من باب السلسله
عاده بهذا المعنى هذه الاقتحامات اليوميه
مستمره طبعا هناك غضب فلسطيني كان لسببين
السبب الاول بان الشرطه الاسرائيليه ابعدت
الفلسطينيين صباحا منعتهم من الدخول الى
المسجد الاقصى لتمكين المستوطنين من
الاقتحام الامر الاخر لان الفهم الفلسطيني
كان بان الليله تقام الليله الاولى من
العشر الاواخر في شهر رمضان وعليه يجب ان
تتوقف الاقتحامات للمستوطنين ويسمح
بالاعتكاف للفلسطينيين حتى نهايه شهر
رمضان فيما ان اسرائيل
الليله يعني غدا ممكن ان تتوقف هذه
الاقتحامات رغم ان قرارا لم يتخذ بعد بهذا
لكن اسرائيل تتجنب في الايام الاخيره وهو
امر واضح بعد ان رات ما حدث من الاعتداءات
اثناء اقتحام المسجد المصلى القبلي
تمتنع عن هذا السيناريو في الايام الاخيره
لا تقتحم في ساعات الليل
المصلى القبلي ولكن التصعيد هو سمه الموقف
الكل شيء يبدا عمليا او بدا عمليا من
المسجد الاقصى المبارك من التصعيد فيه
وصولا الى الانفجار في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله العمليات الفرديه والان هذه
الاقتحامات التي تحدثت عنها تاتي في هذا
السياق روتين التصعيد الاسرائيلي في الضفه
الغربيه وصولا الى اشعال جزئي للجبهات
اخرى مثل غزه لبنان وحتى سوريا شكرا لك من
القدس مدير مكتب العربيه زياد حل بي على
كل هذه المعلومات
من القدس الى اليابان حيث وصفت وزاره
الخارجيه اليابانيه السياسه الخارجيه
والنشاط العسكري للصين كاكبر تحدي
استراتيجيا لنظام الدولي في الوقت الحاضر
وشددت الخارجيه اليابانيه في تقريرها
السنوي على ضروره الحفاظ على السلام
والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان واوضحت ان
اليابان تواجهه اصعب وضع منذ نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه الخارجيه الصينيه ردت
على التقرير وانتقدت بشده تصنيف اليابان
لبكين وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره ان
اليابان تريد استفزاز الصين بالعمل على
انشاء تحالفات عسكريه
وتاجيج التوترات في المنطقه
قانون جديد صدر عن او صادر عن هيئه تنظيم
الانترنت في الصين اظهر ان جميع منتجات
الذكاء الاصطناعي الجديده التي يتم
تطويرها في الصين ستخضع لي تقييم امني قبل
طرحها للجمهور ويذكر المشروع او مشروع
القانون ان الهدف من هذه الخطوه هو
التخفيف من مخاطر التكنولوجيا الناشئه
التي شهدت طفره في الاستثمار وشعبيه عند
المستهلكين في الاشهر الاخيره بعد اصدار
برنامج الدردشه التوليديه
نستمر معكم ونتابع
بعد عامين على الجائحه بايدن ينهي حاله
الطوارئ الصحيه المتعلقه بكوفيد 19
[موسيقى]
بعد الوثائق السريه واشنطن تطمئن الحلفاء
القلقين
يحذر من خطوره تسريبها على الامن القومي
ونتيجه الوثائق المسربه كيف تستبعد اجراء
اي تعديلات على خططها لشن هجوم مضاد مرتقب
ضد روسيا
تزامنا مع اقتحام جنين القوات الاسرائيليه
تشدد الاجراءات في القدس وعشرات
المستوطنين يقتحمون الاقصى
[موسيقى]
بريطانيا تستعد لاضراب خطير للاطباء
احتجاجا على الاجور وتحذيرات من شلل في
قطاع الرعايه الصحيه
احييكم من جديد اعلنت الشرطه الباكستانيه
مقتل اربعه من افرادها في الشبكات مع
مسلحين تابعين لحركه طالبان باكستان في
مدينه كويتا في اقليم بلوجستان جنوبه غربي
البلاد وقالت الشرطه الباكستانيه ان عمليه
المداهمه اسفرت عن مقترب احد قاده التنظيم
بعد ورود معلومات عن مكان اختبائه واضافت
ان عمليات البحث والتمشيط في المنطقه لا
تزالوا مستمره
وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه رصدت 9 سفن حربيه
و26 طائره صينيه في محيط الجزيره رغم
اعلان الصين انهاء مناوراتها العسكريه
الواسعه واوضحت الدفاع التايوانيه ان
الصين حشد الطائراتها العسكريه عند الساعه
الحاديه عشره بتوقيت غرينتش وعبرت خط
الوسط من الشمال والوسط والجنوب مشجره الى
انها تراقب الوضع عن كثب حول الجزيره
عند الحديث عن الحرب نعتقد انه اذا كان من
الممكن تجنبها فيجب تجنبها باي ثمن
اعتقد اننا على الاقل الان في تايوان
محميون على مستوى ما هذا هو الشيء الذي
يستحق ان نعتز به كثيرا في دولتنا دوله
حره وديمقراطيه نسبيا مقارنه بالصين
زعيم كوريا الشماليه دعا الى تعزيز قدرات
الرد على العسكري في بلاده بطريقه بطريقه
اكثر عمليه وهجوميه وبهدف مواجهه ما وصفه
بالعدوان المسعور للولايات المتحده وكوريا
الجنوبيه وقالت وكاله الانباء المركزيه
الكوريه الشماليه ان كم حضر يوم امس
اجتماعا للجنه العسكريه مركزيه لبحث سبل
التصدي للتحركات التصعيديه من جانب واشنطن
وكان امر كيم بتعزيز قدرات الرضع في
البلاد بسرعه متزايده
الى بريطانيا حيث اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه الامريكيه او الى امريكا ان حكومه
بلاده تعتزم انفاق اكثر من خمسه مليارات
دولار لتسريع جهود تطوير لقاحات وادويه
جديده لفيروس كوفي 19 وعلى الرغم من انهاء
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بشكل رسمي حاله
الطوارئ الصحيه في البلاد الى ان المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه اكد ان الخطوه الامريكيه
لتطوير لقاحات جديده جاءت لمكافحه اي
متحور مستقبلي من كوفيد وقال الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن انهم يعتزموا الترشح
الانتخابات الرئاسه القادمه في عام 24
وجاري التحضير للاعلان الرسمي وكانت وسائل
الاعلام امريكيه مشاهدينا تحدثت في وقت
سابقا غموض حول الوقت الذي سيعلن فيه
بايدن بدقه حملته الانتخابيه بشكل رسمي
وفي وقت اظهرت استطلاعات راي امريكيه عدم
رغبه الديمقراطيين في ترشح بايدن لولايه
ثانيه
نتوجه الان الى بريطانيا حيث ممرضون
واطباء ومسعفون معظم الطاقم الصحي في
بريطانيا يدخل على خط ازمه غلاء المعيشه
ويبدا اليوم اضرابا وصف بالكارثي سيستمر
لمده اربعه ايام وفق الرابطه الطبيه
البريطانيه فان الاطباء خسروا 26% من قيمه
اجورهم الفعليه منذ العام 2008 ويطالبونهم
بزياده هذه الاجور بنسبه 35 في المئه هذا
وحذر مسؤولون في هيئه الخدمات الصحيه
الوطنيه من شلل قد يصيب نظام الرعايه
الصحيه خاصه وان الاضراب سيتسبب في تاجيل
ما يصل الى 350 الف موعد مع طبيب وقال
ستيفن بويس المدير الصحي للنظام العام في
الهيئه ان التعبئه الجاريه ستخلف اكبر
تاثير في تاريخ الخدمات الصحيه الوطنيه
وستولد الكثير من الضغوط وحينها ستكون
الاولويه للحالات الطارئه
تنضم الينا من لندن مراسله العربيه عروب
عبد الحق اذا اضراب كارثي للقطاع الطبي في
بريطانيا انقلي لنا الصوره والمعلومات
المتوفره لديك حول هذا الاضراب والمرتقب
طبعا ما يزيد من هذه الاضرابات سوءا انها
تاتي بعد عطله رسميه لمده اربعه ايام بسبب
اعياد الفصح المجيده وبالتالي يعني كانوا
العديد من الاطباء في اجازه في اجازه من
الاساس حوالي تقريبا ال 47 الف طبيب مبتدئ
يشاركون في الاضراب اليوم لمده 96 ساعه اي
حتى السابعه صباحا يوم السبت وهو ما كما
ذكرتي سيؤثر على حوالي 350 الف موعد طبي
واجراء طبي في المستشفيات هذا سيزيد على
طبعا نحن نعلم بان القطاع الصحي الوطني
البريطاني هنا يعاني من ازمه صحيه كبيره
هناك حوالي سبع ملايين من المرضى على
لائحه الانتظار يعني منذ عام الماضي
وبالتالي تاتي هذه الاضرابات لتزيد من
الازمه سوءا ونحن نعلم ايضا ان اضراب
الاطباء المبتدئين كان قد جرى ايضا الماضي
لمده 72 ساعه ثلاثه ايام في ذلك الوقت
شارك حوالي 36 الف طبيب مبتدا في هذه
الاضرابات واثرت على 175 الف موعد طبي
يعني في ذلك الوقت وبالتالي يعني هذه
الارقام تزيد سوءا اما بالنسبه للدعم لهذه
الاضرابات يعني هناك دعم طبعا للاطباء
المبتدئين لانهم يعون بان الازمه هي يعني
ازمتهم ازمه كبيره بالفعل ولكن اذا ما
قراناها او قارنا هذا الدعم بالدعم
للاضرابات في النقابات الاخرى مثلا مثل
نقابه الممرضين فهو اقل بقليل يعني هناك
حوالي بحسب واحده من الدراسات 54% من
البريطانيين او المشمولين بالدراسه يدعمون
هذا الاضراب شكرا لك من لندن مراسله
العربيه عروب عبد الحق
في غضون عشر سنوات ربما يشعر سكان الكره
الارضيه بالامان اكثر لما لا مشاهدينا وقد
رجح باحثون في معهد ابحاث الفضاء التابع
لاكاديميه العلوم الروسيه ظهور نظام
لحمايه كوكب الارض من خطر المذنبات
والكواكبات وقد اكد الباحثون على وجود
قاعده تكنولوجيه لهذا النظام الذي سيحل
مشكله خطر اصطدام المذنبات بالارض على
اساس التقنيات القائمه فعليا
لم تغب اجواء رمضان عن خان الافرنج في
صيدا جنوب لبنان الخان الذي يعود للقرن
السابع عشر تزين بحله الشهر الكريم مع
استضافته نشاطا رمضانيا عن نشاط يعود لدعم
القطاع التربوي في المدينه اضافه الى
تحريك العجله الاقتصاديه بحسب المنظمين
[موسيقى]
سكره
مثل طه
في ال
ورى بهذه الاجواء الجميله تحتفل مدينه
صيدا الجنوبيه لبنان بالشهر الفضيل مع
الاضواء والزينه التصميم المعماري لخان
الافرنج الذي يعود الى القرن السابع عشر
ما رسم صوره رمضانيه ساحره
ولان رمضان يجمع الاحبه انتشرت جلسات
الالفه من الافطار حتى السحور على واقع
الاناشيد الدينيه مع المسابقات والالعاب
اجواء رائعه جدا والاجواء مع الوضع العام
يعني
لبنان ما بده الا روى
بده نظام بده قوانين الناس تمشي على
القوانين وكل العالم بتكون بالف خير ما
بده الا بس شويه امان وكل العالم بتكون
بالف خير ومبسوطه هيدا الفرح والحياه بس
يتركوا له مجله يعيش ماكولات ومنتوجات
وصناعه وحرف عرضها اصحابها في زوايا
الساحه مدى تخيلي عديه نشاط مثل هذا
بينعمل بصيده كل فتره ويا ريت بينعمل على
طول بدنا نضلنا ماشيين مرتاحين كلنا سوا
ضروري نكون نحن عم نركز على هذه الايفنت
وغيرها لحتى ننشط فيها اللي بيشتغلوا من
البيوت بيقدروا اكثر يكون عمنجوا هذا
النشاط نظامه نادي روتراكت وانتراكت صيدا
بالتعاون مع مؤسسه الحرير للتنميه البشريه
المستدامه دعما للقطاع التربوي نحن اللي
عم نقوم فيه هو تحريك العجل الاقتصاديه
يعني
وصناعه يدويه هن هون نحن عم نحاول ندعمهم
سله الضوء عليهم باكثر من عشره الاف واحد
عم يفوت على قلب المهرجان
من الفرح اقتنصها الحاضرون في هذا النشاط
فرح دائم مرادف لشهر رمضان مهما كان
الواقع مرا اضافه الى المنفعه الاقتصاديه
التي تعود بها هكذا نشاطات على المدينه
الا ان الهدف الاساسي يبقى باطفاء البهجه
على الاهالي الذين يحاولون مع الشهر
الفضيل تناسي ازمات بلادهم والدعاء بان
تتلاشى من مدينه صيدا جنوب لبنان ناهد
يوسف العربيه
[موسيقى]
في دراما رمضان جدل كبير على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بعد ان طالما مقص
الرقابه مسلسل الجبل الاحمر التونسي وحذف
بعض المشاهد بحجه انها لا تتماشى مع طبيعه
شهر رمضان المزيد في تقرير كواليس مع سهى
الواعل وايهام القاسم
[موسيقى]
اما نزلنا في الطرح العالم اللي تظلم بخبل
في الكبه وكل شيء مكسور
[موسيقى]
مرحبا ضجه كبيره ويثيرها حاليا مسلسل
التونسي الجبل الاحمر اللي يحكي قصص
واقعيه التقى فيها مخرج العمل باصحابها او
اقاربهم او اصدقائهم حيث امضت ورشه كتابه
المسلسل اربعه اشهر شارك فيها كتاب
معروفين ومؤرخين ايضا هو مسلسل عشرين حلقه
من 45 دقيقه
فيه عدد كبير من نجوم تقريبا 70 من سبعين
الى 80% من الكاستينغو نجوم صف اول
التوانسه مسلسل
اجتماعي
تشويق واثاره لما هي الشخصيه فيها تلوينات
فيها تضاريس فيها
اشياء منتظره كما انه فيها اشياء غير
منتظره تماما هي مثل الشخصيات
تراجيديه وشخصيات الملحميه اللي تعيش
تجربه
ذهاب بدايه
وفي الواقع كل الشخصيات
الموجوده بيناتنا كذلك
تميزها تجربتها الخاصه
الاجتماعي مكون من 20 حلقه وراح ينتهي مع
نهايه الاسبوع الثالث من رمضان حيث يسلط
الضوء على الاحياء الشعبيه في تونس من
خلال طرح مشاكل سكانها وحكاياتها على
مستوى المضمون جبال الاحمر يقوم على اهم
عناصر دراما اللي
[موسيقى]
هموت وهو يحاكي ويقع
الاحياء الشعبيه
ويتناول موضوع من اهم المواضيع الشركه في
وقتنا هذا اللي هو ظاهره الفساد اللي عنده
اوجه متعدده فساد قيامه فساد معنوي فساد
سياسي وانعكاساته على حياه الشعبيه كتابه
الشخصيات في هذا المجال كتبت بشكل واقعي
تجد عن نفس الشخصيه جانب جيد وجانب قد
يكون سيء او جانب متسامح وقد يوجد في لحظه
من اللحظات جانب عنيف وهو واقعي جدا
فساعدنا سيناريو في بناء الشخصيات متاعنا
المخ
رج رمسيس سيء فقط لانه ينتمي للحياه
الشعبي اللي تدور فيه احداث العمل رجاء
مسلسل الجبل الاحمر ليسال لماذا
وحياتهم صعيبه على الضعيف
هذا كرانه مبروك
[موسيقى]
في الختام نذكر بالعناوين
بعد الوثائق السريه واشنطن تطمئن الحلفاء
القلقين والبنتاجون يحذر من خطوره تسريبها
على الامن القومي
ونتيجه الوثائق المسربه كيف تستبعد اجراء
اي تعديلات على خطوطها لجن هجوم مضاد
مرتقب ضد روسيا
تزامنا مع اقتحام جنين القوات الاسرائيليه
تشدد الاجراءات في القدس وعشرات
المستوطنين يقتحمون الاقصى
[موسيقى]
بريطانيا تستعد لاضراب خطير للاطباء
احتجاجا على الاجور وتحذيرات من شلل في
قطاع الرعايه الصحيه
[موسيقى]
في امان الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات